what uh advice would you give to a young
person today in high school and college
that
dreams of doing
something big like young lacoon like
let's talk in the space of intelligence
dreams of having a chance to solve some
fundamental problems in space of
intelligence
both for their career and just in life
being somebody who was a part
of creating something special
so
try to get interested by big questions
things like you know
what is intelligence uh
what is the universe made of what's life
all about things like that
um
like even like crazy big questions like
what's time like nobody knows what time
is
and
and then
learn
basic things like basic methods either
from math from physics or from
engineering
things that have a long shelf life
like if you have a choice between like
you know
learning uh you know mobile programming
on iphone
or quantum mechanics take quantum
mechanics
because you're going to learn things
that you have no idea exists it and you
may not you never you know you may never
be a quantum physicist
but you'll learn about path integrals
and path integrals are used
everywhere it's the same formula that
you use for you know bayesian
integration and stuff like that so the
ideas the little ideas
within quantum mechanics within some of
these kind of more solidified fields
will have a longer shelf life the you'll
somehow
use indirectly in in your work learn
classical mechanics like you learn about
lagrangians for example
um
which is like a a huge
hugely useful concept you know for all
kinds of different things
learn uh statistical physics because uh
all the math that comes out of you know
for machine learning
uh basically comes out of uh was figured
out by statistical physicists in the you
know late 19th early 20th century right
so
and for some of them actually more
recently for by people like giorgio
perezi who just got the nobel prize for
the replica method among other things um
it's used for a lot of different things
uh you know variational
inference that math comes from
statistical physics
um so
um
so a lot of those kind of you know
basic courses you know you'll if you do
electrical engineering you take signal
processing you'll learn about fourier
transforms again something super useful
it's at the basis of things like graph
neural nets which is an entirely new
sub-area of you know ai machine learning
deep learning which i think is super
promising for all kinds of applications
something very promising if you're more
interested in applications is the
applications of ai machine learning and
deep learning to science
or to
science that can help solve big problems
in the world like i have colleagues that
at
meta at fair who started this project
called open catalyst and it's
it's an open project collaborative and
the idea is to use deep learning to
help design
new chemical compounds or materials that
would facilitate the separation of
hydrogen from oxygen
if you can efficiently separate oxygen
from hydrogen with electricity
you you solve climate change
it's as simple as that because
you you cover you know some random
desert with solar panels
uh and you have it you have them work
all day produce hydrogen and then you
shoot the adrenaline wherever it's
needed you don't need anything else
um
you know you you you have
controllable
power
that's you know can be transported
anywhere so if we if we have a
large-scale efficient
uh energy storage technology like
producing hydrogen
we solve climate change here's another
way to solve climate change is uh
figuring out how to make fusion work now
the problem with fusion is that you make
a super hot plasma and the plasma is
unstable and you can control it maybe
with deep learning you can find
controllers that will stabilize plasma
and make you know practical fusion
reactors
i mean that's very speculative but you
know it's worth trying because
um you know it uh the payoff is huge
there's a group at google working on
this led by john platt
so control uh convert as many problems
in science and physics and biology and
chemistry into a
into a learnable problem and see if a
machine can learn it right i mean
there's properties of
you know complex materials that we don't
understand from first principle for
example
right so you know if we could design uh
new um
you know new materials
uh we could make more efficient
batteries you know we could make maybe
faster electronics we could i mean
there's a lot of things we can imagine
uh doing or you know lighter uh
materials for for cars or airplanes
things like that maybe better fuel cells
i mean there's all kinds of stuff we can
imagine if we had good fuel cells
hydrogen fuel cells uh we could use them
to power airplanes and you know uh
transportation wouldn't be uh or cars
and we wouldn't have uh
emission problem uh co2 emission
problems for for
uh air transportation anymore so
there's a lot of those things i think
where ai you know can be used it
and and this is not even talking about
all the sort of medicine biology and and
everything like that right
you know like you know
protein folding you know figuring out
like how can you design your proteins
that it sticks to another protein at a
particular site because that's how you
design drugs in the end
um
so you know deep learning will be used
for all of this and those are kind of
you know would be sort of enormous
progress if we could uh use it for that
here's an example if you take
this is like from recent material
physics you take a monoatomic layer of
graphene right so it's just carbon
on a hexagonal mesh and you make this
single single atom thick
you put another one on top you twist
them by some magic
number of degrees three degrees or
something
it becomes super conductor
nobody has any idea why
i want to know how that was discovered
but that's the kind of thing that
machine learning can actually discover
these well thanks maybe not but but
there is uh
a hint perhaps that with machine
learning we could train a system to
basically be a phenomenological model of
some complex emerging phenomenon which
you know
superconductivity is one of those
uh
where you know think that this quality
phenomenon is too difficult to describe
from first principles with the current
you know
the usual sort of you know reductionist
type method but we could have
deep learning systems that predict the
properties
of a system from a description of it
after being trained with sufficiently
many samples
um
this guy pascal fua at epfl he has a
starter company um that
where he basically trained uh a
convolutional net essentially to predict
the aerodynamic properties of solids
and you can generate as much data as you
want by just running uh computational
free dynamics right so you give a
like a
a wing
airfoil or something shape of some kind
and you run competition free dynamics
you get as a result the drag and you
know
uh lift and all that stuff right and you
can you can generate lots of data train
a neural net to make those predictions
and now what you have is a
differentiable model
of let's say dragon and lift as a
function of the shape of that solid and
so you can do backward understand you
can optimize the shape so you get the
properties you want
um yeah that's incredible that's
incredible and on top of all that
probably
you should read a little bit of
literature and a little bit of history
for
inspiration and for wisdom because after
all all these technologies will have to
work in the human world yes and the
human world is complicated
jan this is um
an amazing conversation i'm really
honored that you talked with me today
thank you for all the amazing work
you're doing at fair at meta
and thank you for being so passionate
after all these years about everything
that's going on you're you're a beacon
of hope for the machine learning
community and thank you so much for
spending your valuable time with me
today that was awesome thanks for having
me on that was it was a pleasure
you